قبل أربعة أسابيع ، أصبح فجر بيكر
أول شخص في الولايات المتحدة يحصل على حقنة
كجزء من المرحلة الثالثة من التجربة
السريرية للقاح ضد فيروس كورونا
، وهي الآن عادت في المرة الأخيرة التي ذهبنا فيها
إلى ذراعك اليسرى الصحيحة
نعم سيدتي ليس فقط للزيارة  حسنًا ،
خذ نفسًا عميقًا لطيفًا ، لكن في
لقطة
أخرى مناسبة ، من
المحتمل أن يتم إعطاء لقاح فيروس كورونا
في لقطتين على بعد بضعة أسابيع ، يبدو الأمر كما لو
أن الملاكم الذي يدخل الحلبة
قد تضربك قد تضرب
الرجل الآخر بلكمة واحدة وقد  اذهب إلى الأسفل
ولكن هناك نوعان من اللكمات سيكونان أكثر
فاعلية وهذه مشكلة لعدة أسباب
أولاً
العديد من الأمريكيين ليسوا متحمسين جدًا
للقاح فيروس كورونا
وفقًا لاستطلاع حديث لـ CNN ، قال 40
بالمائة من الأمريكيين إنهم لن يحصلوا
عليه في
المرتبة الثانية بسبب  أولئك الذين يأخذون الأمر ، إنه
تحد لوجستي أن يأتي مئات
الملايين من الناس
ليس مرة واحدة ولكن مرتين ليس هناك شك في
أن هذا سيكون
أكبر برنامج تطعيم جماعي تعقيدًا
في الإنسان  التاريخ الذي سيتطلب
مستوى من الجهد مستوى من
التطور
لم نحاوله من قبل قبل
أن يتذكر الناس المجيء في
المرة الثانية التي قد يضطرون فيها إلى أخذ
إجازة من العمل
مرتين وربما يعانون من
آثار جانبية مزعجة مثل الحمى
مرتين  يدرك مسؤولو الصحة الحكوميون
أن هذا سؤال كبير
أعتقد أنه إذا أعطيت مجتمع الصحة العامة
هذا الاختصاص ، فسيجدون طريقة ، لكن
المهمة ستكون صعبة للغاية
في نهاية التصنيع ، سيكون الأمر أكثر
تعقيدًا هو صنع 660 مليون جرعة
من اللقاح
أكثر من 330  مليون وليس فقط
ضعف اللقاح ، إنه مضاعفة جميع
المكونات التي تأتي مع اللقاح ،
قنينتين مع غطاءين وسدادين ،
محقنتين مع إبرتين لكل
شخص
يقوم بذلك مرتين ،
سيكون أمرًا شاقًا للغاية
بالنسبة لك.  كانت الخباز تشمر جعبها
للمرة الثانية حول إنقاذ
الأرواح لي
لمنع كبار السن من تمرير مرضانا
من الموت
لم يكن لدي أي فكرة عن أنهم يعانون من مشاكل صحية
بسبب النضال بالطريقة التي يعانون
منها وقد مر بعضهم أيضًا
بالنسبة لي ، الأمر يستحق ذلك حقًا يستحق كل
هذا العناء